it's December 3rd 2019 so it's time for
another monthly update video this is the
last one of the year I'll talk about
what went on in November what we've got
coming up in December and a little bit
about the year to come although I think
I'll reserve that for a sort of end of
year wrap-up video because we've got a
lot of things coming up in 2019 so three
big things I want to put on your radar
right off the bat big thing number one
the runoff vote for the worlds of
speculative fiction series is open until
this Saturday so if you want to get in
on deciding who three of the authors who
all be discussing here locally in that
series are going to be you want to get
in on that you can find the link below
big thing number two we're having our
very last session that's a the only
face-to-face event that I'm having this
month of the worlds of speculative
fiction series focused on the book of
the New Sun by Gene Wolfe I'll tell you
more about that in the December section
and then big thing number three I am
actually raising my rates for tutorial
sessions starting the first of 2019 so
you may want to get in on that right
away and reserve and book sessions if
you want to do that at the current rate
great Christmas present by the way if
you want to give somebody a gift so that
is what we've got for the three big
things all right let's talk about
November 2018 it was not the most
productive month for reasons that I'll
tell you about in a minute first I want
to say to those viewers when I say
remarks like that who weigh in and say
oh you know you work so hard you know
you should you should be easy around
yourself I'm trying to get an awful lot
done so it is important that I can stick
to schedules and get the things that
I intend to finish for the month
finished because there's only so much
time to accomplish these things so what
did I actually get done well we hosted
an event here for world philosophy day
locally in Milwaukee did all the
promotion for it it was you know we held
it here with with in conjunction with
Stone Creek coffee it was me and Craig
Kinnear unfortunately Andy couldn't be
there my wife and partner cuz she was
ill and we were discussing how to engage
in civil discourse with those who you
disagree with the workshop actually went
pretty well I haven't processed the
video from it but it's already been
requested at other places so we're gonna
be doing repeats of that locally in this
area I also finished up the year of the
quarterly series the philosophers in the
midst of history with session number 12
focused on Albert Camus video for that
you can see the link below and we came
close to finishing up the year in the
worlds of speculative fiction series
with the session on Jack Vance's dying
earth really cool one of the
participants actually brought a first
edition of the dying earth in and you
can see that at the very end of that
video which is linked to below did my
usual Hagel Q&A sessions and AMA which
you can find and we did philosophy
pop-up sessions as usual which you can
find in Facebook and in YouTube and
those were focused on something I've
been doing a lot of thinking about which
is a book project having to do with the
the ethics of end-of-life care for pets
and you might say well that's kind of an
obscure topic well we had to put down
one of our beloved dogs who is 14 years
old Magnus this month and that was quite
difficult for my wife for myself for
for my kids and of course for the other
pets and I had this project for a long
time I'll talk about it more in some
other place or you can go to that
session and take a look at it but that
was one of the things that happened this
month that really you know put a wrench
in the works as far as getting a lot of
things done not just because of you know
all of the care that was involved but
you know it's it's hard to put yourself
into doing productive intellectual work
when you're feeling down about these
sorts of things and you're feeling down
together I also got sick three times
over the course of the month I am just
getting over the very last one you know
it's interesting one of my my
interlocutors I'd had to beg go off
because of a meeting because I had a
sinus infection got some antibiotics for
it and then got the flu and he was like
man I thought the antibiotics would have
taken care of whatever you had I said
yeah well they took care of that and
then the next one hit me so there was
that and I've been you know of course
teaching five classes four different
institutions two of which are intensive
compressed time classes so November was
incredibly busy and we had the
Thanksgiving holiday which meant the
kids being here and a good bit of
driving including driving back through a
you know our first winter snowstorm on
the way back from dropping my kids off
in Chicago so I didn't get as much done
as I would have liked as far as video
work and and online class stuff and some
of the other things that I set for
myself I did manage to weigh in on a
podcast on the Tom Ritchie podcast we
talked about voting and we're gonna
revisit some of those issues a bit later
on I did a lot of tutorial work not
uncommon for this time of year good bit
of philosophical counseling work some
academic coaching some ethics consulting
some of which is actually born some some
interesting fruit not here in the United
States but in Australia and of course
quite a lot of editing
work for stoicism today I did do a bit
of writing in my own blog or xst annuity
came and you know managed to do a few
Cora answers as well videos I you know
shot the event videos like I said I
stole oh the footage from the world
philosophy day but I haven't gotten
around to editing it yet I got to Hegel
videos done this month which is better
than the 1 or 0 from previous months but
it's not up yet to my 6 so I wasn't
super happy about that I released some
some Cicero videos core concept videos
that had shot previously and I shot a
few other videos here and there but but
you notice that I've been you know
uncommon ly inactive this this last
month and I didn't do too much on the
podcasting and as well but you know it's
been a very busy month in many other
respects on the personal and academic
front what's going on in the month of
December hopefully I stay illness free
and I'm able to get to the gym and you
know all those other things as we gear
up for the holiday season and my kids
being here again we start the month with
an online event our public Haegele Q&A
session this week Thursday the 6th of
December from 5 to 6 p.m. that's Central
Time of course because that's where I
live and then on Saturday we'll have the
AMA session that's ask me anything
session so if you got questions for me
you can weigh in you can even write them
ahead of time that will be from 12 p.m.
to 1 p.m.
usually they go a little bit longer
because they get so many questions and
then we'll have our only face-to-face
local event and that is that worlds of
speculative fiction series Jean wolf one
I've been looking forward to a long time
his book of the New Sun it's a you know
for book series actually it's a little
bit longer
if you start shoving in some of the
other books after that but but I'm only
going to talk about those four books
beginning with the shadow of the torture
that is Thursday the 13th from 7:00 to
8:30 p.m. at the Brookfield Public
Library then we'll have another online
event philosophy chat which is for my my
patron supporters that is Saturday the
15th of December from 3:00 p.m. to 4:00
p.m. Central Time I'll be doing another
radio guest appearance on River West
radios image for higher show hosted by
my friend the skräuss and we are gonna
be talking HP Lovecraft probably also a
little bit about August Derleth since
hey you know this is Wisconsin and this
is where Daryl a--the was from and this
is where Arkham House was based it's
always a fun time on his show so you can
actually tune in live and listen to it
that will be Tuesday the 18th running
from 9:00 p.m. to 10:00 p.m. I also try
to do a video recording of that one
didn't quite work out last time but
we'll shoot it this time then at the
very end of the month we will have our
MKE stoic fellowship Thursday the 27th
from 6 to 7 p.m. I will of course have
the philosophy pop-ups but I only
announce those in advance to patreon
supporters so if you want to get to find
out about that well you might want to
become a supporter as a matter of fact
it's a great idea anyway if you like
supporting the work that I do for just
$1 a month you can you can get in on all
that and find out all sorts of cool
stuff along the way what else is going
on as I mentioned at the very end of
this month I am going to be raising my
tutorial rates so if you want to you
know buy a session or a block of 5 or 10
and you want to get it at the old rates
the current rates you probably
we want to do that fairly soon like I
mentioned they can be a great holiday
gift for people that you love or think
are in need of tutorial services you
know if you've got somebody who you know
is going to be taking a philosophy class
in the spring and anticipates running
into some some troubles understanding
the material then you might want to
consider getting some sessions I'm also
hoping to get to some writing projects
as well because this month
those five classes that I'm teaching
every single one of them is going to
finish up we have the last two weeks of
class starting in effect today the
online classes of course are just you
know online stuff but they're very
intensive especially as students start
to panic and start writing me about you
know their grades and all their
anxieties and stuff like that and then
the face-to-face classes here in
Milwaukee at Marquette University and
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design we
are finishing up those classes this week
and next week with final exams and final
projects so that's always a lot of you
know grading work for me to do and it
could bit of meeting with students and
and we are still discussing some content
we're gonna be looking at Hana rents
Eichmann in Jerusalem and finishing up
with our business ethics discussions on
the ethics of capitalism this week and
that that will be the end for the
semester I'm still doing a lot of
tutorial stuff as expected some
philosophical counseling some some
academic coaching some consulting work
particularly with ethics that's actually
increasing right now and of course
editorial work as we round out the year
for stoicism today but as I mentioned
I'm hoping to get to some of my own
writing projects I'm working on that
book as I mentioned having to do with
you know how to make end-of-life
decisions for pets in in ethical ways
I'm also working on some academic
writing projects and
some more popular work as well what can
you expect as far as video stuff well
I've got some core concept videos on
Augustin City of God and rents Eichmann
in Jerusalem the Augustine has been shot
already so I'll be releasing those and
the rent I still have to shoot those are
primarily for my students this semester
but I think everybody can get something
out of them this month I'm hoping to
actually get back into the swing of six
half-hour hagel videos per month and so
you know we'll be going back into that
material I'll be shooting some personal
videos as well on a variety of different
subjects that I've been thinking about I
might shoot a dr. Sandler soap box one
if I decide I want to rant about stuff
and I've got to do some book reviews I
know those are long overdue
so I'm hoping to get to them this month
and I'm going to be releasing some more
podcast episodes as I find the time to
actually do the podcasting actually it's
a new podcast I'm taking previous
lectures editing them getting rid of all
the album's AHS you knows that sort of
stuff and improving the sound quality so
that is what I've got lined up for
December I hope that all of you have a
great holiday season and that you can
meet me out here in the ether for some
of these online events and I'll see you
sometime this month
you